hey youtubers is Charlie so hopefully
you guys have seen Batman V Superman
this is going to be my spoilery Easter
Egg video so just careful for spoilers
if you have not seen it yet keep in mind
that the film is about two and a half
hours long the longer r-rated director's
cut is going to be an extra thirty
minutes so there's a bunch of extra
Easter eggs that we can talk about later
this year whenever they release that but
let's just start with the biggest ones
first so number one Batman gets a very
special visit from the Tooth Fairy in
his dreams the tooth fairy also looks a
lot like the flash this is Barry Allen
warning Batman to find Lois Lane she's
the key to everything
he is from this post-apocalyptic future
that connects to Batman's other
nightmare where you see the darkside
symbol the Omega symbol there's no real
context for when that's happening in the
future when the flash traveled back from
but he is time-traveling just seeing
this footage we don't really know what
the rules of time-travel are in the DC
movies because this is only happening in
Batman's dream but number two Darkseid
Omega symbol parademons really mad
Superman in the future like a couple of
the other Easter eggs this is pretty
self-explanatory even if you didn't
remember who Darkseid was you would
probably recognize those creatures and
think parademons Darkseid himself
doesn't appear anywhere in the film so
like none of these things here are
Darkseid these are all just regular
parademons now the three another Dark
Knight Returns he's Drake Barrett in
here a lot of Dark Knight Returns Easter
eggs in the movie you probably spotted a
lot of them some of them were just
visual some of them were verbal
references these soldiers with
Superman's symbol on their shoulder are
an Easter Egg for the sons of Batman
from The Dark Knight Returns comic just
a gang of normal people who are really
extreme but follow Batman so that's kind
of the same thing going on in here only
in this post-apocalyptic future they're
following Superman instead when Superman
rips Batman's cowl off and says she was
my whole world that's what connects to
that other hallucination that he has
when the flash has fine Lois Lois is the
key what it's implying is is that Lois
Lane died and wasn't there to tether
Superman to humanity throughout the film
and a lot of people will criticize the
film for treating Superman in this way
he feels so bummed out about being
Superman he's like maybe Superman never
existed Lois
Lane is the reason that Superman
continues to be Superman she's the thing
that gives him that extra bump to be the
hero number four the death of Superman
that's why you saw the special thanks to
Dan Jorgensen the credits he's the one
that wrote The Death of Superman arc if
you haven't read that run it's not
absolutely essential but it was the
reason that I started reading comics
that was actually the first comic book
run that I didn't just impulse by I
actively sought it out it was like I
need the next part of the story for this
my number 5 Lex's super special
encrypted drive the metahuman project so
just like the flash TV show they're
calling beings with superpowers
metahumans Lex Luthor and I will totally
understand if you want to complain about
this gives all the Justice League
members their special symbols and code
names
cyborg Aquaman Wonder Woman the flash so
digging into these let's start with
cyborg you know number 6 Easter egg
mother box very similar to what happens
during his new 52 origin story there
there been various ways they've
explained how he gets his powers but you
see Silas stone in STAR Labs working on
Victor stone who's got his horrific
Robocop situation going on where Silas
is trying to keep him alive or activate
him somehow that makes it seem like he's
barely alive like he's not quite
conscious but eventually the system
starts working the cyborg system when he
comes into contact with the mother box
and that's what this is they just don't
call it a mother box number 7 the other
flash cameo this is that from the
metahuman file so I know a lot of people
will complain about the ponytail I can't
really argue with that it is a bit weird
the Barry Allen is caught on camera
taking down a convenience store robber
but you see this split frame where he's
holding the milk and taking down the
robber at the same time that's just
meant to show you how fast he's moving
almost as fast as the speed of light
number 8 the Wonder Woman photo this is
taken from right around World War 1 you
see Chris Pine it's probably a scene
right from the movie you will probably
see them take this picture in the Wonder
Woman movie so number 9 Aquaman you see
him destroy a shipping vessel think of
his power the way they visualize his
powers as being like Superman underwater
almost like a sonic boom underwater as
he activates his Trident and just like
flies up towards the sir
at SuperSpeed the way Zack Snyder
explained his powers at comic-con last
year is that his Trident is like Wonder
Woman sword in that they can both pierce
Superman's skin and as long as Aquaman
is in the water he's just as powerful of
Superman in addition to his extra powers
of having control over all sea life so
the evidence that Lex has been
collecting on metahumans as well as the
warning from the future is going to be
the reason for the Justice League coming
together number 10 the dead Robin suit
we've been talking about this for a long
time it's a pretty clear Easter Egg for
death in the family The Joker kills
Jason Todd the next Robin becomes Tim
Drake but it seems like in Batman V
Superman Batman has not had a Robin for
a long time probably since this Robin
died
number 11 Action Comics number one
there's a very notable quote from Perry
White in the movie where it says is not
1938 anymore Clark Kent that's the date
that Superman debuted in the comics so
just an easter egg for the very first
appearance of Superman number 12 and 13
more Batman Easter eggs as Batman puts
his Kryptonian spear in the place where
he fights Superman to the death you see
the Riddler's question mark on one of
the pillars you see another pillar with
the J and a smiley face so just seating
things in for the new Batman solo films
they haven't really said anything about
which villains they're actually going to
be using in the new Batman trilogy but
expect some very familiar faces from the
rogues gallery
number 14 the Mark of Zorro so you see
the Zorro poster in the opening credits
sequence that explains Batman's origin
story how his parents died in most
versions of the Batman origin story he
is partially inspired to take the Batman
persona because of Zorro now in a lot of
the comics they actually walk out of a
Zorro movie in other versions it's the
Opera but Zorro has always been this big
creative influence on the Batman
character number 15 also saved from that
opening credits sequence not necessarily
a batman easter egg but Bruce Wayne's
parents played by Jeffrey Dean Morgan in
lauren cohan our two actors from the
walking dead
he is playing negan a crazy villain and
she plays Maggie so nice Easter Egg for
the walking dead in Batman's origin
story number 16 you have to save Martha
most of you probably realize this when
you're watching but both
Batman and Superman Smothers names are
Martha
they don't really spend too much time
addressing in this in the movie but
Batman feels that he's like oh okay I
get it
Martha will not die tonight I will save
your mother and give my mother some
closure
number 17 Easter eggs for the
Christopher Reeve Superman pulling him
away from the Kryptonite out of the
water if you remember in the original
Christopher Reeve Superman movie Lex
Luthor puts a chain of Kryptonite around
his neck dumps him into the pool he
starts to drown and they had to yank him
out so nice visual reference for that
number 17 Easter eggs for Superboy or
bizarro depending on how you look at it
Lex Luthor in the comics creates a clone
of Superman that they'll call Superboy
Conner Kent using his DNA in DNA from
Superman so him adding his genetic
material to the Kryptonian birthing
devices he creates doomsday the
abomination is a nice Easter Egg for
that but you could also consider Pizarro
because in various versions of the
comics Lex also creates bizarro which is
something of an abomination
number 18 Jimmy Olsen that photographer
with Lois at the beginning of the movie
is Jimmy Olsen
Zack Snyder explained they didn't have
room for him in the Canon they're
creating for the movies so they wanted
to do this thing where they have this
surprise death they were going to do
this Ned Stark thing where you kill this
really big actor really on in the film
and there's going to be a big WTF but
originally he wanted this to be Jesse
Eisenberg Jesse Eisenberg came in to
audition for the role but after meeting
with Bryan Cranston for the role of Lex
Luthor Zack Snyder decided to go with a
younger actor so when he saw Jesse
Eisenberg come in for Jimmy Olsen he
made the switch so we picked this other
actor to be Jimmy Olsen still killed him
but it didn't end up being the big WTF
that he originally intended it to be I'd
argue though that it's still a WTF for
those that feel like Jimmy Olsen is
critical to the Canon of Superman so I
will totally understand if you want to
rage against them killing Jimmy Olsen in
the movie universe number 19 Easter Egg
this has to do with some of the
marketing around the film they were
marketing that Lex Corp is working on
artificial intelligence Lex is able to
hack the Kryptonian ship to use the
birthing chamber carla Gugino is
actually the voice of the AI she was the
voice of the AI and Man of Steel so kind
of an Easter Egg for that too but you
see a straight line between the
self-aware AI that Lex is trying to
create the Kryptonian ship in Brainiac
so just expect to see more shades of
that during Justice League Brainiac
isn't justice league level villain
anyway and I'll say last big one is the
appearance of kryptonite which actually
originated on the radio show The
Adventures of Superman the really really
old school radio show the reason they
created kryptonite was the the original
voice actor that did the Superman
character a break from the show they
would do broadcast every single day so
it was just brutal on the actor so they
created a reason for him to have to go
away and that reason was kryptonite so
there are a ton of other visual
references to the Dark Knight Returns
like the pearls like you look this this
looks exactly like the way his ex
nighter shot it there's a lot of that in
the movie there's a lot of characters I
think there was even a Senator Ferris as
in Carol Ferris so if you guys spotted
any other big Easter eggs just write
them below in the comments giveaway time
though congratulations to the most
recent giveaway winner Spencer Caudill
you win to IMAX gift certificates be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I get your contact
info that's just on the about page so
what's going to happen next is there's
some Game of Thrones stuff that I want
to do a video for just to take a quick
break from DC stuff then I'll do another
Batman V Superman video about some of
the Wonder Woman Justice League stuff
going on they've started to release some
more information about the next couple
films that are coming out so be sure to
subscribe to get that
if there are any specific bonus videos
that you guys want me to do or any
aspects of the film you want me to do a
bigger video about just let me know in
case you guys haven't seen it I did do
like a broader non-spoilery review of
the movie you can click here for that
and you can click here for the trailer
for next week's episode of the flash
there's some really cool stuff thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you